brie larson and samuel l.jackson holy
our cameras were invited to the
top-secret set of Captain Marvel doesn't
it look like we're waiting in line to go
on a ride at Disneyland yes right
we can't help but marvel at her good
fortune being cast as the most powerful
superhero in this universe but her
favorite part of the whole thing this
suit for a while I was just trying
everything on in pieces it took probably
close to a year because everything
everything is like a different craftsman
that's like eight different people that
so different parts of the costume and
then when I finally put it all on
together we did get emotional this
origin story helps set up the next
highly anticipated Avengers movie due
out in April and it has brie doing most
of her own stunts well part of it was
just ignorant I just thought that that's
what was required okay so I carved out
nine months to Train and kind of retool
everything and it wasn't until we
started shooting that I realized I've
been nobody does their stuff you're not
a vlados thing you'll see did you fly at
all in your training I did fine you did
it was amazing yeah I want to do it
again is life changing
while most of the plot is shrouded in
secrecy
we know the film is set in the 1990s and
it reunites Bri with her conne co-star
samuel l.jackson a Marvel movie veteran
so you're back with Bri what's it like
hooking back up with her again you say
that like it's a you know a thing said
it like this is Wonder William self so
you back with Bri so you hooked up with
her I'm looking at you and I'm seeing
what's going on with the dots and what's
what's happening here the same things
you guys do except you know big dots
with my botox I look younger by the time
the movies ever did say I'm give you any
kind of I don't know introduction to
this world and say okay here's what's
gonna happen
he has to go to dinner and I thought
like oh he's gonna this is the moment
sit me down and be like these are the
big life lessons of the world my
mother's been like hmm still just like
shooting the breeze i'ma get my big
thing it was like you don't need to hear
anything for me I was like oh my god
it's so profound
it's very saying everything without
saying nothing Captain Marvel his
theaters March the 8th
[Music]